hi guys in this video we're gonna talk
about in a minute fasting I want to give
you the big idea of in a minute fast I'm
going to show you how to prevent
problems if you're new to this this
video is mainly for new people I'm going
to show you how to do them in fasting
the correct way so this is representing
12 noon 6 o'clock p.m. 12 o'clock
midnight and 6 in the morning
ok the goal of intermittent fasting is
to change the pattern of eating so
you're actually shifting running your
body on glucose to run your body on
ketones ok and in this transition things
can happen you can have like
transitional symptoms if you're if you
have certain deficiencies of nutrients
the most common supplements that people
take to supply the nutrients they're
usually the missing nutrients would be
salt okay that's one why because when
you're running your body on fat fuel and
less than carbohydrate you're going to
dump a lot of water because carbs retain
fluid so you cut in the carbs you get
rid of fluid with the loss of fluid
comes a loss of potassium magnesium and
other electrolytes so it's very
important to add back in the salt sea
salt potassium magnesium you can take an
electrolyte consume a lot of vegetables
so but in this video I'm not going to
cover like exactly what to eat I'll put
a link down below for that this is
mainly the intermittent fasting part so
these supplements are important to make
the transition very smooth so many
people are deficient in magnesium
potassium B vitamins and so everything
is magnified when they go into ketosis
which is burning fat and then B vitamins
are very very important in the
metabolism of you know fats even protein
and even carbohydrates so we recommend
nutritional yeast as a good source for B
vitamins get the one that's non
fortified that way you don't have to
deal with all the synthetic B vitamins
that are out there some of the symptoms
that you may experience in this
transition fatigue headaches nausea
dizzy rash dehydration symptoms and also
your
acid symptoms so you may have a little
touch of gout because uric acid in your
body has another function as an
antioxidant so your body is raising
certain antioxidants to actually help
counter the oxidation it's part of the
healing process but this is temporary
it's not an issue I'll show you how to
resolve it and you may even lose some
hair if you're deficient in B vitamins
vitamin b2 for example is needed to
metabolize fats so if you're actually
eating more fat you're going to need
more b2 you're also gonna need more b1
so to avoid all these if you take these
you shouldn't experience any of these
okay these are not normal these these
just show up when you actually have
deficiencies so anyway these are some
things that you can take okay so let's
say for example you get up at 6 o'clock
in the morning and you drink coffee if
you want to speed things up you can get
some MCT oil okay
that's a certain type of oil that will
actually convert into ketones so if you
take MCT oil it has a different
metabolism than other types of fat and
you'll increase ketones which means
you'll feel like you're in full ketosis
but you're really not you're in a
transitional phase but you may be let's
say it's three days in or two days in
and you're like forty percent in your
ketosis but not a hundred percent so
that's why you might have a team so to
make this easier on you you could
actually take an MCT oil build-up the
ketones so you'll have not just energy
but you know that fat will allow you to
be satisfied to go longer with your
fasting okay most people eat at 8:00 in
the morning
12 at noon six and a half snacks in
between what we want to do is we want to
start with like a 16-8 but do it
gradually so it's easy so I mean you can
start with just with three meals no
snacks then you go to meals no snacks
but sixteen to eight means that let's
say for example you ate at 10 o'clock in
the morning as your first meal and 6
o'clock as your second meal
that actually is eight hours okay that's
your eating window you could actually if
you need to eat something in that window
you can it's not advisable but if you if
you need to go ahead and do it but
ideally it would just be eating two
meals 10:00 and 6:00 and then from six
all the way here we have our fasting
period at sixteen hours okay that would
be the first step but what you're doing
is you're pushing this first meal
forward each day you push it forward and
the rule of thumb is you don't eat
unless you're hungry so you just need to
go longer and longer in the morning
until eventually there is no breakfast
you're just having your lunch as your
first meal I personally like to consume
my eggs and bacon at as my first meal my
first meal is like right around here but
that's my so-called breakfast but I'm
having it at lunch by late lunch some
people have a blood sugar problem okay
they're a diabetic or they have inter
prediabetes
and so they may find when they do this
that their blood sugars are higher in
the morning when they wake up so I want
two men just mention that I have a video
on that but I just wanted to mention
that that usually is because they have
what's called insulin resistance and
another reason is that this hormone
cortisol which is a stress hormone
spikes at 8 o'clock in the morning ok
it's not exactly at 8 it could be like
at 7:30 or 8:30 but when cortisol spikes
it mobilizes glucose for the flight or
flight mechanism or the action that your
body needs so it needs this sugar and it
also suppresses insulin so we have the
situation where we have high sugar and
when we wake up in the morning and just
realize this is a temporary situation
but it would be very very smart to
exercise this sugar off to burn up this
sugar through exercise in the morning
and I really recommend people exercise
in the fasting period ok so if your
first meal is right here and you're
exercising right here you're you already
are in hardcore fasting and you exercise
top of that you like you'll see even
more benefits than if you exercise
right after the meal so this is what I
recommend right here now getting back to
this uric acid thing citrate counters
uric acid as in lemon juice
so maybe 1 to 2 ounces of lemon juice in
water
slug it down you can add apple cider
vinegar and that will help your blood
sugars but the citrate will counter uric
acid and also it can counter kidney
stones
some people are prone to kidney stones
it's rare but if you're pruned to it
then citrate would be very very
important also drinking more water would
be very very important so then we have
our first meal at 12:00 noon and then
let's say our second meal at 6:00 so now
we're at 18 and 6 we have a 6 hour
eating window ok and then we have 18
hours of fasting that's when you start
noticing some serious benefits with
cognitive function less inflammation a
lot more weight loss now if the person
has insulin resistance
they usually have fatigue after they eat
and the fuel is not going into the cell
so they'll eat and they're not satisfied
and because you eat in general there is
going to be a spike in insulin and
pre-diabetics retire buttocks have more
insulin than other people and that that
insulin is going to make them tired
after they eat because they have the
spike there so they're gonna feel like
they're there wanting to take a nap but
as they do in a minute fasting for a
longer longer period of time this
tiredness goes away they'll start
absorbing nutrients in the cell they
won't get tired anymore so it's very
very therapeutic and then of course you
have the 20 and 4 and you're eating
let's say at 2 o'clock and your second
meal is at 6 that's a 4 hour window with
20 hours of fasting you can get even
more benefits from doing fasting from
that but there are a lot of people that
are in their 40s and 50s and 60s that
have a slow metabolism and they need to
lose a lot more weight and that's why I
recommend the ohm at one meal a day ok
so we're gonna do 1 mil a day so that
would be like 23 and 1 alright so the
best time to eat is later in the day or
even like later than 6:00 because when
you start eating between 6 and
9 you're gonna be eating in a period of
time where your body is more
parasympathetic and that's part of the
nervous system that's responsible for
relaxation and digestion they'll get
better digestion this could be why a lot
of people like to snack later at night
and in that case I would recommend if
you're doing two meals do a meal run
here and then do a snack let's say
pistachios as you're sitting in front of
the TV so it's kind of like a meal and a
half okay and then you work on pushing
this meal forward and forward and
forward to the point where you have just
one meal somewhere between 6 o'clock and
9 o'clock and that way you're gonna eat
enough food where you're satisfied and
if you're at one meal a day your weight
loss is gonna be so much faster I mean
if you have a lot of weight to lose why
mess around why not just jump right to
here lose all the weight as quick as
possible
it's not an unhealthy thing it's a very
healthy thing realize that the amount of
food that you're going to eat in that
one meal though is not going to
necessarily be the same calories as
three meals because it's just too much
food but the nutritional requirements
are a lot less when you're doing in a
minute fasting because your body gets
really conservative and it starts
recycling nutrients and proteins so you
don't have to worry about trying to get
the same amount of calories and if you
have blood sugar problems it's not a bad
idea to add a little outside of vinegar
maybe a teaspoon or a tablespoon in a
glass of water in the evening and you're
gonna find your blood sugars will be
actually pretty good through the entire
night and especially in the morning so
your next step is to get started I put a
link down below to give you this in
writing thanks for watching so if you
want to get notified with all my content
click the notification bell next to
subscribed